TBS has already cast the Trump Russia
scandal movie and it's only like two
days old we got ahold of the casting
list you want to hear it I thought so
here we have first up pretty good
casting here first up the Russian lawyer
who Donald Trump's jr. met with will be
played by Leah Remini which is something
pretty good casting yeah deputy yeah
deputy White House press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders will be played by
imprisoned dance mom Abby Lee Miller
Eric Trump will be played by Draco
Malfoy
[Applause]
[Music]
you'll get your spotter he says that all
through the movie no one knows why Jared
Kushner will be played by Hilary Swank
and boys don't cry Donald Trump jr. will
be played by this punching dummy you see
in any Jam yeah Ivana Trump will be
played by Janice from the Muppets
president Donald Trump will be played by
Prince Charles cuz that just worked out
of this I don't know
First Lady Melania Trump will be played
by this board housecat wearing jewelry
Donald Trump's personal physician dr.
Harold Bernstein that's the before photo
dr. Harold Bernstein will be played by
comedy writer Bruce Vilanch
Attorney General Jeff Sessions will be
played by Dewey from malcolm in the
middle' publicist and russia go-between
Rob Goldstone will be played by the
mucinex mucus monster
Russian President Vladimir Putin of
course will be played by crew from
Despicable Me
and finally Kellyanne Conway will be
played by a plate of fried eggs and
bacon
[Applause]
you